this is sort of a weird segue this
actually would be a weird segue no
matter what the last story was but I
need to talk to you about male sex
robots we've talked about sex robots
before and usually the conversation is
about you know the legality of the sex
robots or the psychological impact or
the cultural and societal influence that
sex robots might have how would sex
robots affect relationships or a
conversation about the technology
underlying a sex robot itself that's
usually what we talk about when we talk
about sex robots this is not one of
those conversations it has been brought
to my attention that a male sex robot
soon to be released by a company called
real bot --ax looks kind of like me it's
name is Nate and we have a picture up on
the screen for our audience and it is
pretty damn creepy and one thing as we
look at the picture Pat that was pointed
out to me is that the eye color doesn't
match this is a very very light I
colored robot and I agree with that but
there is definitely some kind of weird
resemblance to me it's not a perfect
match and it's it's very very odd the
hairstyle may resemble you but ten years
ago perhaps okay before it was
controlled yeah before the advent of
hair products this reminds me of a
Seinfeld episode and I don't know if
you've seen this one yet Pat you're
working your way through the Seinfeld
series there's one where there's a
clothing store mannequin that looks a
lot like Elaine Lee and there's this
whole thing where I think Kramer goes in
to steal it or something like that maybe
we can order one of these when it goes
on sale and it could sit at the other
chair when we do a wide shot and it
would just it we would never mention it
yeah I would never cut to the thing but
with no explanation whatsoever there
would be a robot that kind of looks like
me the only downside to that would be if
we have visitors it would be a little
bit perturbed by yes they would but it
would be good for when building
management comes in to tell us that
there will be six more weeks of
construction and they see that thing in
the background it might just scare them
and they they'll does not bother us or
they could use it or they could use it
who knows anyway in case you're curious
there's a recent report from Bice which
says that the technology is definitely
still in a
infancy the male sex robot the female
sex robot is moving ahead very very
quickly
okay although the the male sex robot
technology is is still there's still
logistical issues to be sorted out
dramatically anatomical reasons why yeah
there's sexual function issues and some
other stuff that needs to be sorted out
but anyway this is the Nate model which
is weird because 'not on is my brother's
name which is of course like the hebrew
spanish version of nathan the nickname
for which is nate and it just imagined
for a second that the designer said i'm
gonna make it look like david pakman but
will put his brother's name on it so
like we'll kind of know that it's based
on him but it won't really have his name
yeah and now i want there to be a male
sex robot in my likeness too yeah well
I'll talk to Plato about developing